qu'en sera-t-il de l'après coronavirus y
sont nombreux à se poser la question
dont prescillia ludo ski une des figures
des gilets jaunes elle a récemment lancé
sur internet une pétition intitulée
après kobe 19
stop aux inégalités sociales une
initiative visant à tirer les leçons de
cette crise sanitaire historique une
pétition déjà signée par près de 2000
internautes
le gouvernement doit repenser les
modèles de société selon la gilet jaune
priscilla à lui de ski je proposerai
dans l'âme édition c2c qui est plus de
coordination entre les pays et qui est
là où collaboration et que ce soit sous
la forme d'un pacte contre les
inégalités sociales retraites
internationales mais je parle du constat
de ce qui s'est passé en france pour
dire voilà travailler ensemble entre
pays pour que les inégalités ce ne se
creuse pas davantage on a bien vu les
différentes manifestations qui a eu du
corps du corps ainsi des corps
enseignant du corps hospitalier et elles
ce sont des professions qui réclame un
certain nombre de revendications et qui
ne sont pas entendus qui ont même été
réprimées lors de manifestations et qui
aujourd'hui on voit le manque le mans
que se fait sentir les agissent avec
urgence en commandant un tas de matériel
médical ce qu'ils auraient pu déjà faire
avant lorsque ces manifestations avaient
lieu donc enfin tout ce qui est pointée
dans la pétition c'est de dire mettez
les moyens en place pour que si ça se
produise à nouveau en soient mieux
préparés mais entendez ce qu'on vous
avait déjà précisé avant